6 33 expect thanksgiving travel to look
a lot more crowded than last year when
we were in the middle of the pandemic we
have vaccines widely available and
international borders have reopened for
travelers in fact tsa is saying that
this year could be very close to
pre-pandemic levels millions are
traveling across the country so we sent
hector out there to check things out
hector it has just been building
building building and it's only 6 30 in
the morning
it sure has a lot of early flights we're
seeing you know we heard airlines are
doing everything they can to avoid any
staffing issues down below we have
american airlines and off in the
distance way out there we also have the
check encounter for southwest airlines
so far at this hour we haven't seen any
issues in terms of long lines down below
however the tsa check-in area here the
security checkpoint for the a and b
gates starting to build up but it's not
too bad joining us live we have joe
rachel with mccarran airport to tell us
all right so before you get out here
what should people know us locals in
terms of parking absolutely give
yourself plenty of time to park and uh
plan ahead you know what we've seen is
that the terminal one long-term garage
is going to fill up and so we want
people to have enough time if they get
redirected to either terminal 3 or the
economy lot to depart get get on their
shuttle and get here in time would you
say worst case scenario plan perhaps
maybe an additional one hour yeah we're
saying at least you know an hour just to
accommodate for you know
parking getting on that shuttle getting
the shuttle ride over here um and just
giving yourself plenty of time all right
so if we're staying in town we'll you
know probably having family visiting us
what should we know in terms of heading
out there to the passenger pickup area
yeah if you're picking up a loved one
you know we ask that you utilize our
cell phone lot where you can wait for
your loved one they can call once
they're at the passenger pickup lane you
can go get them you can be on your way
or you can utilize short-term parking
but you know we just don't want the
roads getting congested with people
doing loops awesome joe thank you so
much for your time don't forget if you
haven't traveled in a while masks are
mandatory and also you can't bring on as
a carry-on any liquids over three three
ounces so you can't bring on your gravy
or let's say your cranberry sauce we
have a link on our website
eightnewsnow.com that explains
everything you need to know before you
get through the tsa checkpoint reporting
live hector mejia live local now